hello
and welcome to the stream
this is hans kim
hanging out here just getting the stream
started
getting annoyed by the audio equipment
um
i am
living in a house now
i paid rent for this this is
uh
my real home
so that's pretty cool
um
i uh
copy link i wanted to
do a little podcast it's been a while
um
let me post about it on instagram
i don't know how to get the link without
starting it so i had to start it and
then post it
um but yeah i mean i'm living in a house
now
link her
whatever
i forgot to say what i was doing but
anyways whatever this is my room
it's nice it's uh room shaped
uh it's a beautiful little room
it's not really supposed to be a bedroom
they just built it
[Music]
they built it and this is like a
multi-purpose space
um
no this is not the mic that i returned
to kohl's that was another pair of mics
uh little lavalier mics to do on the go
it's like about 10 bucks each not really
a big deal but yeah i live in a house
now uh that's why i've been away from
the live stream game
is because i was busy housing it up
living my life as a housed person
[Music]
but yeah i mean
i'm having a good time just trying to
get some white on my face
so that i can appease my american
audience
hello
i am asian man and i will do anything
for la raf
hahaha asian asian donkey donkey asian
penis [ __ ]
small small kimchi dick
um but yeah i mean a lot of people are
trying to maintain my integrity as an
asian man and calling me out for any
perceived slights against my own race
i really don't care about race and
i don't have to have an undying loyalty
to my race to feel good about myself
i think that uh the race is pretty cool
that i am and that uh
it's not really a big deal if i'm not uh
completely hundred percent loyal to the
asians
the small [ __ ] bad driving [ __ ]
sucking asians
um
i love uh kill tony um it has been the
best thing in my life besides you know
whatever random girl's having sex with
me right now
um but yeah i mean
who wouldn't love the attention and
adoration of thousands of thousands of
hundreds of thousands of listeners every
week
um but yeah kill tony has been great for
me it's been great for my career it's
really my only credit i mean if i didn't
have kill tony i'd have some [ __ ]
like sirius xm and audible.com
but obviously i don't give a [ __ ] about
those i care about kill tony and that's
really what i'm happy about um and i
love kill tony and i love the show
before i was on it and now i get to be
on it i get to be on my favorite show
it's an amazing dream come true
and it's just an amazing thing that
happened to me and it's kind of scary
it's like maybe this isn't real maybe
i'm still stuck in the desert
in of california just dying of
dehydration and this is just a fever
dream and i didn't really get to meet
joe rogan and get paid
thousands of dollars just to open for
him
um
[Music]
as
i mean i i love that i get to do this as
a dream come true i didn't realize that
if i moved to austin i'd be opening up
for rogan and
you know
doing kill tony every week this is like
not even
the
uh wildest pipe dream for me um so this
is an amazing thing that happened to me
and i'm having a great time
um
so yeah i mean
i am uh
professionally successful in my chosen
career
um
there's a lot of um
sexual sexual uh success as well i'm
sexually successful
so this is uh the face of a successful
sexually successful man
so i mean well look at you guys um
looking at me the the peak of
masculinity and sexual
uh
bravery
is me hans kim
um but yeah i mean uh
i'm professionally successful and
well i'll be i guess not but i mean i
did pay for this apartment with comedy
money
so that's pretty successful in my
opinion
um
and also a little bit of unemployment
money
but um
i do love sex
so that's an important thing that i'm
getting because i kill tony
so you know it's been great for me in
very many ways um
[Music]
you're lucky i'm not you're there to
destroy you all at catan
oh no please don't destroy us we're just
original little boys with tight [ __ ]
we don't want your giant mancock to
shove into our bodies and fill us up
with your man semen
um
yeah the van life is sort of retired
um
i had sex yesterday in the bed uh this
bed right here
uh real life full intercourse with human
female
that's the uh name of my porn video
that i'm gonna post it on
um but yeah van life van is still out
there i use it as a driver
um
so that's just what we're doing
uh
i just am enjoying the whole thing
that's happening
um
yeah you don't have to
uh no more van life watch out for herpes
bro
going on rogan ever yeah whenever i'll
have you on what was his name
back to the boring apartment sex life
yeah who wants to have sex in an
apartment where there's
a stable foundation and
people
aren't just random homeless people
walking around listening to you [ __ ]
um
i uh i've had a good time i mean i'm
sorry about the lighting in here i got i
ordered a ring light i got the
prime membership trial
so i have it for like two months or one
month or three months
so then i just cancel it after three
months and i get to have multiple
accounts
i set up already so i just cycled
through it and i get prime shipping
for free by having multiple accounts and
signing up for the trial membership i
got a new phone i already cracked it
um i don't know if you can see it but
it's cracked
over
here um but it's an iphone 13 pro max
you can tell because i got the [ __ ]
wall-e
cameras on the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
on the [ __ ]
iphone so that's pretty cool
um
yeah i mean uh
it's been a while since i've been doing
this
so
yeah i mean i do hack the system a lot
i'm sorry that i returned the
microphones that i used to podcast back
to amazon sorry bezos we worship you and
we love you we hope that you can bless
us with your
beautiful merchandise and warehouse jobs
um
but yeah
i'm looking to go into full-time rv life
says savage god
13.
there's 13 savage gods any suggestions
for the road life yeah
p
a lot
p whenever you have a chance to
p in the middle of the desert pull over
and pee even if you don't feel like it
just go peeing a lot
um
i have a lot of shows in austin coming
up next friday and saturday i'm
headlining the roma room that's the show
that i want you guys to go to i'm also
at the secret group whenever i'm in town
which i will be this week and next week
hopefully
um
[Music]
i i would love to get 200 million
dollars from spotify so
please let x know
um so any advice for rv life full time i
would just say
um don't drive when you're tired you
live in a van on an rv you can pull over
anywhere and sleep so you should you
should be getting lots of sleep i would
say sleep a lot
i know this is not normal for you
[ __ ] cubicle dwellers and [ __ ] you
know uh [ __ ] of capitalism but you
don't have to
be awake at any time you don't want to
be anytime you want to go to sleep
that's an option you can just go to
sleep it's pretty cool like when you're
tired go to sleep when you're
not tired stay awake when you're hungry
eat listen to your body and just do what
it wants and take care of yourself for
once in your life instead of using your
body as a
device to make
other people more money use your body to
optimize your potential and perfect
the profession that you chose to
get into
yeah you don't have a boss telling you
when to go to sleep and when to stop
partying and when to [ __ ] in a bucket
you get to tell yourself when you want a
[ __ ] in a bucket
and you get to fart whenever you want
and that's just a freedom that a lot of
idiots will not understand
and they will just be
continually holding in their [ __ ] and
piss
waiting for
a boss
or a middle manager
to tell them what to do and when to do
it and then they'll just explode but
that's not you buddy you're going to be
in an rv you're going to be [ __ ] and
pissing whenever you want however you
want
so that's pretty cool
uh you get to sleep when you're tired
and eat when you're hungry that's
that's my advice
listen to your body don't listen to
people telling you what to do
the only person telling you what to do
is yourself
um
do you ever argue with tony et cetera
about politics never i love my job
um
i feel like more asians didn't have
katanas and moments of shame we would
have more hans kim's
if more asians didn't
oh so you're saying that if i had a
katana
katana i would have stabbed myself in
the belly out of shame out of the sheer
shame of being
the most kissable lips on kill tony
oh what a what an embarrassment i am
this beautiful sex god i'm bringing
shame to my family by spreading my seed
into every
stripper i can meet
um what do you do to stop
procrastinating and being lazy what i do
to stop procrastinating and being lazy
is be filled with existential dread and
worry about who i am and if i'm worth
anything and also [ __ ] i'm also
motivated by [ __ ] so that uh if i just
want to sit in bed all day i'll be like
actually i want some [ __ ] so that stops
me procrastinating i feel like there
doesn't need to be a superhuman push and
drive to succeed and do well
it doesn't have to be a [ __ ]
herculean effort it can just be a nice
pleasant
uh push a gentle
nudge in the right direction to do work
um
and i don't think that it has to be
coercive or anger driven or
hateful or
uh strenuous
work should be easy
work should come to you easily if it's
not then it's not sustainable so you
should just like [ __ ]
uh procrastinate when you want to
procrastinate and then when you don't
want to procrastinate you should make up
for that with superhuman energy and
zeal
so i mean the more you procrastinate the
more that you're gonna have to make up
for it so
um
yeah i would say just uh
don't uh [ __ ] overdo it don't think
that you need to be motivated by us by a
superhuman motivation the motivation
should be coming easily and nicely and
beautifully
and you don't have to wait for uh
you know the will of genghis khan to
move you you can just move yourself with
the slightest nudge
in the right
direction um
and hard work is not just reserved for
meat heads and morons
but uh yeah i mean you can do it uh
gently and nicely and
it's all about
the area under the curve
so like if you do work
a lot then you're gonna do
more work overall it's like if you do
work every day
for an hour
and you do it for seven years that's
better than doing a lot of work for one
year and then burning yourself out and
quitting
and we live long lives
we are not turtles but we are also not
octopi
um
people are asking about lsh
i think lsh is a very funny comedian and
i hope him
good fortune he's very nice to me
he's a very nice gentleman and um i'm
glad that i get to know him and hang out
with him and be with him he's black so
he is uh
really good at
the moment and
you know being cool
and i am very good at being awkward and
weird so together he's cool i'm awkward
and weird it just sort of evens out to
be
a good neutral couple
um
apparently i'm on a show tomorrow is it
in my calendar okay yeah
i should post about it
um but yeah i mean um
i think ellis has uh got a great
opportunity and i'm excited to see what
he does with it and i think that he's
got a lot of energy and a lot of like
good vibes and i think that it's awesome
that i get to hang out with him and
um that we all get to see him develop
and grow
fave cookie is definitely teddy grams
welcome to the stream i can tell you're
new
um because my favorite
is
teddygrams.com
check it out
uh
hans i think it would be an eight not a
seven if you put a wig on
thanks shaun b
i do try to keep a slim figure um and
i try to shave my nipple hairs so that i
can be more sexy as a
woman um
i've never met a woman with nipple
actually i have
but she was kind of fat and i think her
hormones were a little bit off
um but yeah most girls don't have nipple
hairs
which is nice
maybe they just shave it really well
it takes a lot of work
to shave everything as a woman
um
i love
the female body
it's uh
it's awesome to be around them it's kind
of hot in here i'm gonna go see if i can
turn the ac on one minute
so my roommates are outside let me know
if you can hear them or if it's too
annoying i uh i have to get used to
roommates
these [ __ ] idiots making so much
noise all the time just background noise
um
i uh
i turn on the cool air it's 75 degrees
in here and
the thermostat said at 68 so i'm just
getting used to apartment life
and being able to change my
climate whenever i want
it's a little bit of a weird time right
now because the roommates are loud and i
just don't know what to uh
do
um
thank you justin for the ten dollars
a lot of people are saying all octopodes
are a sec bisexual
yeah i'm out of the van i bought a house
um i don't live in a van because i love
cars or because i hate
normal human
habitation i live in a van because
i
want to save money and if i'm getting
money from comedy and it's a sustainable
income source
then
um
i will buy a house and live in it uh so
that's pretty cool
um
i cannot hear anything in the background
that's good because they're making a
ruckus and that means i can do this
podcast even when they're being loud and
annoying it'll just bother me internally
because they turn on the podcast at 10
a.m in the morning and i'm downstairs
right next to the living room so that
it's like i wake up at 10 now
[ __ ] annoying
uh
[Music]
i didn't see owen benjamin shout me out
why the [ __ ] did owen benjamin shout me
out what did i
how does owen benjamin know about me
does he watch kill tony
um but yeah i mean
i think it's great that um
i'm just knee-deep and [ __ ]
how many ig followers does a comedian
need to have a stable job
um i think the number of ig followers a
comedian needs is a
corollary
it's a third party effect
the number of followers a comedian needs
i think is
not relevant a lot of people make money
with just like 10 000 followers a lot of
people don't make any money with 50 000
but here's the thing um
i
am
doing fine financially and it doesn't
even cost me that much i don't have the
super
need to make a lot of money i'd rather
make good art and that's what this
shitty podcast is all about is
making good art and trying to
perfect the art of talking alone into a
camera because then i can
do this sustainably for a long time
um i like this setup i can do it by
myself i ordered a ring light then i'll
be full and complete and then i won't
need anything and i'll be really really
happy
um
[Music]
yeah i mean a lot of people buy their ig
followers uh some random guy decided to
gift gift me a bunch of ig followers
when i was starting out so
some of those are fake that you see on
my ig
but you know it's just interesting
because the people who care about that i
don't care to impress so yeah like
whatever some of them are fake
but it's not like i asked him to do he
just did it for me so it's not like i
did anything illegal
and i don't really care about the the
number in terms of my self-worth
obviously i care about the number
because i love seeing it go up and being
like oh i wonder how many followers this
person has or if like that person has
more followers than me and it's like
it
i don't
i i still don't understand how famous i
am or how not famous i am it's like
kind of crazy
uh how
how people know me now like i'm a part
of the [ __ ] comedy scene and the
celebrity uh you know culture that i've
been watching thus far
as a
observer and now i'm sort of a
participant i'm still unsure how to
participate in it and utilize it fully
but you know
um
i i'm just doing whatever i wanted to do
and it's just awesome that i get to
do whatever i want to do because even if
i didn't have
fame or success i would still be doing
this kind of podcast i mean i did this
before
during the pandemic i was just talking
to myself and it's just fun to do
because it's like what do you need to
talk
um they i heard on dawn of everything
but dave david graber and david
one growth
that uh humans can only sustain
conscious thought for about
like 10 seconds or seven minutes or
something unless you are talking to
someone and if you're talking to someone
that you can sustain conscious thought
for an even longer amount of time
um i do have a link for my merch
um
let me let me go try to log in and do
all that
um
so yeah i mean
[Music]
um
let me see
my link for the merge
is this
i don't know if you can copy paste that
but
um what's your favorite song to play on
guitar
oh i bought a guitar so that's pretty
nice
i don't know why but the audio is [ __ ]
up is the audio [ __ ] up i hope it's
not [ __ ] up but i bought a guitar
i love guitar
um trying to find a good place to put
this wire
hey there a chat stream i'm just just a
lonely boy and i'm just a sad little boy
and i have
really really sad cumstains on my pants
i wish that i could come right now
but i'm on stream
i want to come i really want to come i
need to come i need to come i need
come all the time
well i don't know how to make it pick up
the [ __ ] guitar
um my [ __ ] mic is just
tuned just for my voice it's like a good
dog
um
[Music]
i don't know i don't know how to do
anything but that
um
i don't know how to pick up the guitar
sounds
i'll have to figure it out
um but
yeah i don't know whatever
uh but yeah i mean i think that uh the
guitar is cool
um
[Music]
i uh
um
no i haven't been working out i need to
work out um i want to work out i think
it'd be cool to work out
i just don't know where to or
i don't know
yeah i mean my neck is always an issue
so that's kind of annoying
um
but yeah i mean
i uh i'm just hanging out having a good
time
hopefully you guys are good
um
so
something that we could talk about
what's your first thing you are going to
smash your guitar on straight rockstar
life
probably
i don't know do you still have the
telecaster i don't know what the
telecaster is
uh
i play cities and knights expansion for
katana i have played cities at night
there's a lot of fiddly diddly stuff so
i don't know if i like it that much
but i do love the islands i might have
to buy the island [ __ ] next because i
think that's a really cool way to play
and then you get to mix and find out
what the new [ __ ] is
have you eaten i have eaten i just ate
oh [ __ ] let me go turn the oven off
so i just turned the oven off i only
meet me i uh eat a lot of ribs and
chicken
and i eat kimchi but not a lot of
vegetables
and it's kept me pretty lean pretty mean
and in the game
uh i can play basketball
i'm uh moderately athletic so it's just
like you know like this is a good diet i
think it's what cavemen ate and i it
doesn't bog me down of course i eat a
lot of shitty food i'm not an athlete i
don't keep myself to a strict
strict diet
i eat whatever is fun and whatever is
available but overall i try to eat
healthy i haven't asked joe rogan for
any elk meat yet that i would feel like
is an imposement like why am i asking
him for anything he's already given me
so much in terms of cash money
so so it's just interesting that
i would ask him for anything more
anything that he chooses to give me i
would be
really honored to get but i don't want
to cause him any extra attention or
thought than he wants to give me i don't
want him to be like oh i gotta give him
the alchemy i gotta remember
i don't want
to have him
to be a burden on him at all i want our
interactions to be frictionless and
smooth like a
baby's butt
um but yeah i mean uh the thought of
asking joe rogan for [ __ ]
is uh
it's like my fear of heights i just want
to run away from the idea that
um
i just want to make sure that
the people that i'm texting and stuff
are uh
not angry at me because i want to
hang out with some of them
in a interesting way
um
[Music]
okay so this guy apparently sent me
money
i gotta [ __ ] maybe i shouldn't do this
live or whatever
open up
okay whatever
um thoughts on joe's controversy i think
that joe rogan should have freedom of
speech and he should be able to say
whatever he wants
um i think that you should be able to
say the n-word
i don't think that uh
it's about like oh you broke the law
you
disobeyed the thing uh you are hereby in
violation of the code i don't think it
should be like oh you said a word now
you're in trouble i think it should be
like
oh you hate black people and you voted
to give them less money you are hereby
banished
i think that's what cancellation should
be reserved for not people who say a
word
and i don't think that um you have to be
a bad person to say the n word i think
that you can just be saying it because
you don't give a [ __ ] about the society
around you like if you're in the middle
of the woods and you said the n-word
like um
it's not like you hate black people it's
just like you uh
you you don't want to hurt black people
you're just like i don't know expressing
yourself for
rapping you know
um but yeah i mean this is like
i think that uh
this is what black people get to do like
they've been through so much and they've
had the short end of the stick that now
they get to like ruin conversations and
cancel celebrities like yeah that's like
the least that we can give them like you
get to [ __ ] be annoying at parties
or
uh censor people over words
like i feel like that's a fair that's
like not even a fair trade that's
they're still coming out behind and like
we should actually give them a lot more
but until we give them like money and
like
um
[Music]
financial restitution and an equal
opportunity to succeed in america
that they get to cancel us and they get
to police our speech and
they get to dance better than us and
make us feel awkward and
weird
because they paid for it they get to
um if asians have been through that then
i would like to be able to
[ __ ]
[ __ ] with white people or be like hey
you you can you know say [ __ ] it is our
word
i am a [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
uh montreal i would love to go to
montreal
what if you hate black people but don't
use n-word
yeah that's like still a problem
um
i just think that
you know black people
they uh they've been through a lot and
a lot of people don't want to
uh
[ __ ] fix the issues
so until we fix the issues they're gonna
be annoying
and we're just gonna have to get used to
that
um
but yeah i mean i think that black
people are really amazing people and
that they are
doing a lot
with the shitty position they were given
and they're like amazing they're like
really talented
hey whoever you want to hate love
whoever you want to love
um just don't hate don't let your hate
get in the way of someone's financial
success
or prevent them from getting
opportunities
which group of black people the the
black group of black people
afro-americans
a job on getting all the hot chicks you
can come to new mexico and a park on my
land in the mountains
sounds like a great way for uncle albert
to fiddle with my [ __ ]
if i want an uncle albert to
explore the inside of my body i know
where to go in new mexico now
no i'm just kidding i'm sure uncle
albert has a beautiful piece of land
i'd love to go what's your favorite
historical tragedy
probably the tragedy of
the uyghurs or the palestinians it's a
modern genocide it's a legal genocide
leave it up to the jews to genocide
through
laws and
official channels
anyone can go to africa if they want
well it's not really a very beautiful
destination for economic freedoms
because of colonization
and uh
you know
exploitation by the europeans
so i mean you [ __ ] up their homes
you're [ __ ] them up here you're
[ __ ] them up everywhere they go
it's just a tough time for them and so
they get to uh
tell us what to say now
until
they start getting [ __ ] [ __ ] until
you start giving them money reparations
and then maybe we can say the n word
and if they uh you know have better
after school programs maybe i can
you know start dancing better than them
but uh you know until that happens they
get to uh [ __ ] with us so i mean fair
trade
uh uyghurs
what who's
we should all be talking about the
uyghurs
you know
like like the saying goes i'm as eager
as a uyghur
uh to talk about the uyghurs
um
and i'm not just being meager with my
attention i would love to think about
uyghurs and they're half chinese
half middle eastern faces
being exterminated by china right now
what's your favorite ethnicity probably
latinas
or
you know
someone sexy some sexy race ethnicity
did you see the idubbbz sam hydoc no did
it just come out i love idubbbz he went
to like some [ __ ]
fat guy who does lightsabers
uyghurs are hard to concentrate on us
killed a million iraqis and wants to
talk about uyghurs
yeah i mean
who
who knows how many iraqis really die
um
i think that
it's hard to moralize
internationally
um did my blanket just move
there's nobody here i'm all alone
black people have more opportunity than
special needs people in this country
look who your friends really put down
well black people are
you shouldn't compare a race of people
to special needs people
um i'm sure that uh
special needs people can [ __ ]
do great things
uh what about those people han san
tsuchi turned her back on
i think the are you talking about is
like uh
that woman i forget burma or myanmar or
whatever
and she's a politician
and she uh there was a muslim ethnic
minority there
that were getting exterminated by the
army
and i think she was just a president
that was just like [ __ ] you guys did
what okay okay i got your back on this
but don't do it again
so she went in from the international
community was like they it was actually
a military exercise
and i think that she's just like trying
to manage her crazies her trump
supporters in her country and she's just
you know taking the blame for it but
obviously if she was like to control
every part of her country it wouldn't be
[ __ ]
uh killing muslims
rohingya or something
i'm going to chicago in may please check
the link tree in the description
i got tickets i'm going to rosemont in
chicago so please come in may
uh what about black special needs people
lol yeah they have it the roughest
they uh
they get to say the n word they get to
say
n word [ __ ]
uyghurs in space
yeah i mean hopefully they don't get
[ __ ] up there too
the uyghurs are gonna go into a wet
market in space if guys could create a
robot with functioning incubator ovaries
and all would men do it
um
i mean it's like if you get a robot to
be exactly like a human except better
i don't think it's a question about
gender i think it's just a question
about mental health
obviously hanging out with uh crazy
people uh who are dying of economic
poverty is not ideal
and if you could create just a whole
society of people that would imitate
human beings
perfectly then that might be better
i would hate being special needs and
getting beat
yeah i would hate to get beat at all
poor black special need people omfg
but the good thing about being poor
black special needs is that you can
dominate in the special olympics
you uh
you can dominate those [ __ ] white
people
with your superior
yet also inferior genes
your extra chromosome
hopefully
it goes on the leg
come on han solve all these world
problems already we need you
um
america's the only country to have
committed atrocities when every powerful
country today has a dark
history um yeah i mean america is pretty
good at it though
we have a pretty good dark history we
think we beat the world right now
in terms of the recency and the impact
special needs are good at taking [ __ ]
things slow special needs
they should have a special forces that's
all special needs
and the dna
wouldn't they'd be like oh no these
aren't humans
let's let them pass
um i think that uh
special needs people are very special
and unique and awesome
um
this microphone i got from amazon.com
i love amazon.com
because
it's
a
um
convenient thing to do
let me see if i can
send this as a message
um
or in
um but yeah i mean
i think it's funny that uh
i think that uh
special needs people really make you
think about
why you're nice are you just nice to
people because they can do something for
you because they're in charge of
something or
are you nice to people because
it's
how you treat people that's how
that's what you do when you see a person
you treat them nice it's just a habit
it's just a pattern
and then it makes you think like if
we're just stupid
uh are we still human
are retards humans
and then it's like well what if they
were slightly more [ __ ] and in fact
didn't have any arms but had little
flippers and actually had gills then
would you uh
would you still consider them
eligible for
humane treatment
uh and i think that um
we are human beings and our we have
weaknesses and one of our weaknesses is
that uh visually we see something and
then we respond to however it is uh
that we see so
to train ourselves to be like oh i see a
person i'm nice to them oh i see an
animal i'm nice to them i think that's
the how you're supposed to train a
person
in fact i'm not stoned at all
um so i think it's just good
um
yeah i mean
i just think retards make us think about
ourselves and
whether or not we should be nice to
people who aren't
able to do everything in their power
that a normal person can to help us out
but there's like things that retards can
do that to help us out and just because
they can't help you out doesn't mean you
shouldn't be nice to them
um
[Music]
but yeah i mean uh
i'm having a good time
it's all about your personal enjoyment
and my personal enjoyment is enhanced by
the success of my species
and also i think that my species gives
me a lot of meaning and i would be
willing to sacrifice my life for
it
so that's my afterlife is just
you people continuing on
um
[Music]
so the thing is like um the palestinians
are being exterminated but luckily we
have recorded their
culture in
digital forms so their culture will live
on and even though their dna might be
exterminated we have a record of what
their culture was like so we can
culture can be
re-invigorated
and with palestinian dna maybe we could
create future palestinians to continue
the traditions and culture of palestine
so you know congratulations you made it
to the digital age you are recorded you
are
uh
you know cataloged so relax you might
die out but we'll probably make you
again if we want in the future
um so you know it's not really a big
deal that your homes are getting
destroyed and
your existence on earth is a little less
rich because the people
who have power have decided to
exterminate your home
and create a new one and
um
yeah it's kind of sad
but uh yeah from korea our culture it
looks like it'll be around for a little
bit longer
even though our population is decreasing
and we're not creating enough new babies
um but yeah
i think like having more
babies and stuff is like important but
not that important
um
i think that um
what is your metaverse strategy my
metaverse strategy is to
um
excel
and
repopulate the earth with my semen
um my metaverse strategy is just to
chill and have a good time and
eat lots of stuff
instagram
um
i uh
you'll get canceled before you get
started i wish
um
if i get cancelled i have my van i can
go into the desert that's what i love
about it
is the
vendiness of it all
okay i think i sent it
it's your fault hans you're gonna be
making new babies in korea well if i
have two
babies with the white women then that's
one whole korean so the dna gets passed
on
um
so i mean
i'm trying to make up for it i'm trying
to
trying to spread my seed
um i think that i could be even more
successful sexually i'm trying to work
on my sexual skills
and trying to get it so that uh girls
want to have sex with me
even
even hot ones
um
[Music]
kanye well
brian laundry was a victim of cancelled
culture
yeah life canceled him he shot himself
in the head or something
i am still talking to elise elise is a
very nice lady
who did shoot a man once out of
self-defense
and uh you know i fully stand by her if
i try to attack her i would want her to
shoot me
in the upper torso as well
um just to you know snap me out of it
guns are guns are crazy
um
what was your favorite part of living in
korea my favorite part of living in
korea was probably living in america
because i've never lived in korea i mean
i was there for like a month or two
so i guess that's living in
but um
[Music]
uh kanye i think he's a little crazy i
think he's an interesting guy i think
he's just like not very good at
expressing himself sometimes and i think
that he's a product of a sick society
and he's trying to communicate with us
so he says
uh he's been shaped and molded by our
society he's been gifted every awesome
thing that we have and this is the kind
of person that turns out to be because
when you are that's fabulously wealthy
and successful in a society full of
poverty and desperation you have to sort
of divorce yourself
from society
to uh maintain your high level of output
and if we had a society where everyone
was at the peak of their performance
then we would be able to have a
synergistic effect and we would be able
to better ourselves but unfortunately
we um we live in a world where very few
people are successful and everyone else
is a miserable cubicle jockey or a fast
food employee
and uh to live in a society like that
it introduces uh perverse incentives
where people who are struggling will
just latch on to famous people and try
to make it so he has to watch out for
that
he has to watch out for a bunch of
people who aren't uh intellectually
satisfied and performing for them and
finding music that works for an audience
of
illiterate um
cattle that are used to produce more
profit is not an ideal situation for an
artist i think this is this is just what
happens when you become successful in a
corrupt society you turn a little crazy
you divorce yourself from the society
that you live in
um
and it's just um just an interesting
thing
to see uh
our society reflected back to us in
kanye this is the best of us and we
[ __ ] him up because we
are a [ __ ] up
society um but i do think that
we could have a better society if we
just all work together and figure it out
make everyone awesome
um
i think kanye west is a very creative
person he's an empath he feels the
society around him and he uh channels it
through him
and uh he's been channeling a lot of
gunk and mess because uh that's
what we do um
i uh
i think that uh
it's good to be delusional so that
you're happy you know it's like if
you're always in this world and always
like keeping up with the news and
like with the energy of everyone else
then you're just gonna be sad and lonely
so it's good to uh [ __ ]
just divorce yourself from that and just
um
you know
um
just do
different things and
and uh
and just just be like i'm just gonna
check out and just [ __ ]
you know
live in my imaginary fufu lily land
anyone tell hans at least got arrested
for shooting someone yes we talked about
this elise shot someone in self-defense
and uh the guy apparently was attacking
her
or about two or something
he was i don't know i don't know what
happened but um yeah i mean
you know sometimes you gotta shoot a
[ __ ]
wait you're an atheist but you think
kanye is an empath zero evidence for
that too i don't know what me being an
atheist has to do with
kanye
i think having empath
dick qualities
yeah i'm in a house right now i bought
it with my kill tony joe rogan money um
i owe my
livelihood to them i am a human being
now with comfort and luxury so it's been
pretty good i'm 32 i started comedy when
i was
24 5 six ish
uh
she was shooting with alec don't worry
about it
uh you ever listened to a cemetery no
should have dodged the bullet
his fault
yeah if you get shot by a woman that's
like you're not even a republican
that means you're a liberal
you can't
you shouldn't ever get shot by a woman
you should only get shot by men
um i'm a feminist where's your house
texas yeah in austin texas i'm gonna
register to vote
uh and then i'm gonna buy a [ __ ] gun
[ __ ]
probably a glock 19 or an mnp
i forget who makes m ps
uh mnp
uh smith and wesson
you know either or
whatever works it's really for
self-defense i'm guessing i'm going to
spend like 500 600 on it
um
[Music]
what's my strategy and content to get
the most resources possible so whatever
gets me the most dots
so the most valuable numbers are seven
but seven
is um a robber so you can't get it
but the next valuables are six and
eights
and fives and nines
so i just try to get the most dots most
high and then whatever the resource is
coming in and i just do whatever i can
with that
um
my thoughts on guns is that if you own a
gun statistically you're much more
likely to die by a gun
yeah and who doesn't want to die by a
gun that sounds [ __ ] awesome
you mean if i buy a gun i'm going to die
in the most awesome way possible yes
please i'll spend 500 to die awesomely
well you're just not going to spend any
money and die in a hospital like a
[ __ ] cow like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
um but yeah i mean obviously it's more
dangerous to have a gun but it's also
more dangerous to go 70 miles per hour
on the highway
you gotta take some chances in life and
live an awesome life you can't just put
yourself in a bubble and reduce all
likelihoods of horrible things happening
to you because you gotta [ __ ]
have increase the likelihood of awesome
things happening to you as well
so
this is sort of my philosophy
guns i think
should not be a part of society but i
live in america they are so if i'm
already living in a society that has
guns and i don't have a gun that's
probably the shittiest position to be in
uh so yeah i'm gonna get a gun
and i'm gonna practice with it and i
think it's an awesome thing to get good
at it's modern
uh knighthood
it's like if you were living in the
1600s
and you could buy a sword why wouldn't
you buy a sword and then why wouldn't
you go in your backyard and start
swinging it around and pretending you're
slicing up
huns and asian
mongols and
the asiatic hordes
from the east
koreans
don't get a katana at birth katanas are
japanese we steal katanas and melt them
to create korean swords and processors
and samsungs and
kias
um but yeah i mean i would love to
practice a gun and be proficient with it
i mean i did jiu jitsu which is like
a shitty gun so i might as well get a
gun and practice that and then i could
have the ultimate security and
peace of mind knowing that i can define
defend myself
if i should need to and
it's just an awesome thing that people
can do is like murder other people and
i'd like to get good at that because
like
that's uh part of uh
being a human is like martial arts
uh and guns are the ultimate martial art
um
i would like to hunting rifle
i might get a hunting rifle
because i want to go hunting with it i
want it to be practical and honestly
shooting people is not that practical
and i could shoot a person with a
hunting rifle it would just be more
annoying
but uh yeah i mean i was gonna get a gun
a pistol because um i'm living in a van
and it's hard to swing a [ __ ] rifle
around in a van
um but i might if i if i could i would
just get two guns but i don't know if i
have enough money i've been spending
money like crazy recently
when am i doing joe rogan's podcast oh
yeah let me let me just go do joe
rogan's podcast real quick i'll be right
back i forgot i was i just i forgot
about it i'm just gonna go
do joe rogan's podcast right now
sorry about that i forgot
murder is just a part of being a human
well not murder i mean i'm a human and i
haven't murdered anyone but i've thought
about murdering people a lot
and um you know it's like thinking about
murdering people and practicing
murdering people it's like humans are
our only
predator we're apex predators the only
thing i have to defend myself against
those other humans
so to have safety against the number one
predator to humans i have to learn how
to use a gun
and why would i not learn how to use a
gun
because if i don't then it doesn't
satisfy my animal need for safety and
security i need to be able to murk these
[ __ ] that i see in the streets
every day and if i don't have the
ability to shoot and kill everyone i see
then i don't feel safe i'm an american
what do you want me to do i need to kill
people to feel good about myself
i need to be able to extinguish people
and make them disappear so that i can
live my individual life
uh
in utter disregard of everyone else
america
uh blood or [ __ ]
hans written house you mean hansen house
hans in the house
blood or a [ __ ] i mean blood just sounds
better [ __ ] is like weird
air 15 won't help in a natural disaster
but it will help in
a human disaster
um
gotta have a gun
you know a lot of countries that have uh
normal
governments that are in check
like in iceland and in
japan
and i guess japan might not be that good
example but a lot of countries where the
government listens to people they don't
have any guns
um i don't think guns are necessary to
get governments to act i think you can
give your population guns and still
exploit them
as is happening in america by not giving
their
workers any rights so yeah we have a lot
of guns and what are we doing with it
we're just shooting each other and
shooting children in schools and we're
not getting any more rights we're not
getting any more [ __ ]
uh money for the workers
so yeah i mean keep giving us guns and
keep stealing our money because we are
too stupid to be able to do anything
about it
um i think every kid should be issued a
gun at age 10.
um
i think every kid should be issued love
at age 10 and maybe even before probably
age zero would be a good age for love
do you believe in any crazy conspiracy
theories
um
i live near two gun shops i must change
the narrative
i'm australian
yeah i mean why wouldn't you
have a gun guns are cool
they do what we pretend to do in sports
they murder people
i don't really believe in that many
conspiracy theories
um i think i think conspiracy theories
are
um
just like
what uneducated people do to fill in the
gaps in their world view
uh and it's like they have a hammer
which is just be like oh my god i'm
freaking out i need to freak out they're
really good at freaking out so they just
like use their skill of freaking out
to um
to try to tackle all their problems and
solve politics
and they're like you gotta understand
that they're they're out there and this
is so bad and it's so crazy
it's like i think that you want to act
like this and then you just made up a
logical backstory
that would allow you to behave in this
manner
uh what is the percentage of socialist
revolution in this century
i think very high
uh and if you
uh if socialist revolution means more
power and money to workers
it's inevitable um right now we have an
upside down pyramid that's very unstable
it's very unstable to be giving all your
money to billionaires
and it's
not going to last so
once they're toppled it'll be
more money and power to everyone else
and we can live in a functioning society
and i think that's what it boils down to
we went from kings and queens in feudal
europe uh and asia then down to
uh capitalists and
billionaires and rich people ruling over
us in capitalism
now we just need to keep moving that
power down through the hierarchy and
give it to everyone
on your girl having a serious criminal
past i think it's very uh [ __ ] up how
uh elise was treated in the press i mean
she shot a person
and then they put out a new story right
away and they're like look this woman
look how crazy she is she shot a person
and then there was no follow-up story
there was no like getting her side of
the story it's just like oh you know
these women they'd be shooting they
always be shooting men
all these hard-working men getting shot
but it's like why don't you follow up
you wrote a whole [ __ ] story and now
when you search your name that's the
only story that pops up is what happens
what the story that they wrote right
after she got arrested like they're not
interested in a back story they want
clicks they're like oh a woman doing
crazy [ __ ] and shooting someone that'll
get clicks
but uh you know a woman
uh coming out afterward and being like
hey
he was attacking me in self-defense or
whatever that doesn't get clicks so
it's just
they just saw a story and they wanted it
to use it for whatever
so they did it
europe in asia what about africa yeah
africa wasn't really
that impactful on modern
uh politics for some reason
you still believe in journalism from
traditional news outlets yeah i'm just
saying how it's stupid i'm saying that
uh i don't believe in it
uh in a very specific example to do with
elise
this is a paper towel
oil is a renewable resource takes a
while to renew it
uh we gotta
get a bunch of tree stuff and dinosaurs
and compress it in the earth for about
500 years
um
on screen is whoever is paired you're
squatting at not letting you have katan
parties
um well i live here i am a resident i
have a right
uh to be here so
i can technically invite people over uh
no no one is stopping me
but myself and my need to be a polite
roommate
uh no the whole us rule has revolved
around the bushes the clinton got let
off clinton's got a lot of charges by
them being in arkansas by them in
arkansas in the 80s trump is a pal of
the clintons etc
um yeah i mean
i don't know how good of friends they
are but they do serve the same purpose
which is to keep this [ __ ] going
the way it's going
um
and i mean trump is good if you know
that things need to change but you don't
really want to change anything
so it's like yeah let's put him in
charge he's he represents something
different because it feels different but
in fact he's just advocating for the
policies that we've been doing forever
it is true i'm a mechanical engineer and
a hell of a hell of a hell of a hell of
a hell of an engineer it's a song that
they sing in georgia tech
what do you get frustrated by i get
frustrated by women not having sex with
me when i think they should because
um i'll eat their box
i don't even have to penetrate them i
just want to see them experience
pleasure
and sometimes even when i'm not trying
to [ __ ] them they're just like
um
even when i have pure intentions it's
just
not a fun time to hang around women
because they're always afraid of getting
raped all the time
um but yeah i mean it's cool
that uh
they're always like that they're always
anxious and they're always suspicious
and they always think the worst of
people
um but not all women uh just
most of them
uh but yeah i
don't really want to rape anyone so
whenever someone treats me like a rapist
i'm just like oh so that's just how you
treat everyone
um but yeah i mean obviously i can be
annoying i can be like horny and not
really there intellectually just there
physically
but
i mean if
the only thing that um
that you're going to show me is fear and
accusations then it's hard to
be there for that kind of thing
intellectually and be open emotionally
um
i'm sorry i'm an incel
i
think that
women
need to [ __ ] more people
and that uh if we were all [ __ ] the
world would be a better place
um
i love you slanty jesus
jesus hey
i think you're racist
what if jesus came down and he was
racist that would suck
i would hate that
what are your goals with comedy
um
to connect with the audience on a deeper
and deeper level
as i progress through my career to
convey messages that i think need to be
heard
to
explore the different uh
you know
uh thought processes
and strategies for dealing with the
world
and present it in a comedic humorous
light
um
you think there's more men that aren't
getting laid than are definitely
definitely a lot of men are not getting
laid have you ever been to a comedy open
mic have you ever been to any place
where men talk a lot
uh that place is full of men talking
about how they're not getting laid
um i think that we are having less sex
than before there has been surveys about
this because at least in the 50s they
were
you know signed up to one person and
they [ __ ] them their whole life which
sucks but now like we're not even
getting that we're just like
out there and then like women are trying
to [ __ ] people for uh retirement plans
and
health care and food and then men are
just trying to get uh enough finances to
be able to attract a woman
and
um i think that a lot of people are not
[ __ ]
and i think that if we were [ __ ] more
it'd be a better place i think that um
we express ourselves sexually and to not
be able to express yourself sexually it
cuts off a part of who you are
um
and i think that uh yeah we should be
having more sex with each other and that
would solve a lot of our issues
and it's not up to like men just to be
[ __ ] awesome and
you know just [ __ ]
get really good at tricking people into
[ __ ] them it should be a 50 50 thing
and ladies need to start um
saying yes to sex or just like not just
sitting there waiting for someone to
convince them
and uh you know like trick them into
[ __ ]
uh but uh actively
you know making an effort and um
you know
like
being open to it themselves you know
maybe start by touching yourself so that
you know how to come
um
[Music]
and not looking at sex as the man
winning and the woman losing but as like
two people
touching each other's buttons
for pleasure
but yeah i mean it's uh easy for me to
say like oh women just need to start
[ __ ] more it seems easy
uh for them to do but obviously there's
like a lot of social pressures and like
if you just start [ __ ] people
in a society where no one's getting
[ __ ] then people you're gonna attract
a lot of desperate people so it has to
be all at once we can't just have like
outliers just start trying to change and
start the revolution themselves
uh but we need everyone to just start
[ __ ] and then
we can check up and find people that we
like
something you just want to straight up
tell some someone you want to
please them but you can't
uh does the union make us strong yes the
union makes us strong
we are all strengthened by the union
i mean capitalists have property and
power and they own the deeds to the
factory and they use the police
to get what they want
union workers have a union and together
they can bargain so if you just let
capitalists have all the power and you
have the workers do nothing
then
then there's a power imbalance and then
the capitalists get more and more power
so you need a union to keep them in
check but we made it illegal to do
wildcat strikes we made it illegal to um
[Music]
do other things related to unions so
workers labor
late workers rights are severely
diminished
and capitalists can charge
whatever they want and pay workers
whatever they want and in a true
free market workers would be able to
[ __ ]
fight back and get what they need from
capitalists instead of just getting
capitalists to do whatever they want
um i did return
mics at kohl's
those mics were lavalier mics they were
used to record a podcast that is out
right now with misho shakur in new york
city i was not in my home with all my
equipment
i needed equipment
in new york so i ordered it to new york
and then i returned it when i was done
with it and i didn't really feel bad
doing it because the thing is amazon is
rich enough and they can afford to
sponsor my podcast
and i thank them for doing that
i mean look at the unionization rate in
america like you don't have to make it
illegal you just have to make it
prohibitively
uh difficult to join
um
and that's how they do voting
restrictions they don't make it illegal
to vote if you're black but they don't
put in a voting station near black
neighborhoods they make the ids that you
need to register to vote specific to
white people and not stuff that black
people would have
like food stamps
and um
they don't let college ids be used as
ids because we all know how college
students vote
um
what's the best book
you've read hans probably sex at dawn i
like britney legislative joke of that
one guy using cole's cash and going ham
was singing with that for weeks
yeah britney's a great person
what's racist
what do you say you that's enough
to ensure we should expropriate the
capitalists they don't have the right to
that wealth anyway
um
yeah i mean we don't even have to
expropriate capitalists we can take a
page from their book and make it
prohibitively prohibitively expensive to
be a capitalist and slowly chip away at
them little by little every year and
soon they will disappear their kind will
be no more and they will be exterminated
from the face of the earth
um
obviously that's
a better thing to do is to
slowly make the world a better place
we don't have to do it all of a sudden
and make it so violent and aggressive
although if you want to do that you know
we you have every right to because we've
been exploited and
uh
you know [ __ ] with for years so if you
feel the anger and the need to do that
to capitalists you know who am i to
defend them they've been starving people
for fun for years
starbucks amazon gender have all been
caught using illegal union busing
tactics recently check out status q news
on youtube
that's great i'm glad that uh someone
has the facts
and the knowledge to back up what i'm
saying
when i don't
wait if there is no capitalists that
leave communists
um you mean a community you mean us
human beings in a society together yes
that is what we have
currently
hans how educated are you
what official
signs of education do i have i have a
bachelor's of science bachelor of
science in mechanical engineering
um
and that's the education that i have but
i don't think that education only comes
in official forms i think the official
forms of education are very useful and
powerful but obviously easily exploited
and
turned to whatever
[Music]
need that you have
joe rogan have you guys ever shared
philosophies props for your journey and
blessings for what's ahead joe and i
have had very deep conversations joe has
nothing but deep conversations
um
and he's uh
he's really good at talking and yeah
i've talked to him and he's talked to me
and we've shared eye contact
uh what little i have and what little he
can
see of my eyes we've looked at each
other
and
[Music]
i am proud to call joe rogan a great
friend of mine i think i'm allowed to
say that
i don't know what i'm allowed to say but
joe rogan did call me a friend once
um when he was criticizing the way that
i
um get a little horny around women
he was like hans you got to get your
[ __ ] together i can't have you people
being like joe rogan's friend is like
creeping up on women again
so he called me a friend then i don't
know if that counts do you think don't
love hackathon
you're an engineer yeah a hell of an
engineer what are your favorite idioms
or cliche listen to your gut did you
ever work full time as an engineer yes i
worked at a startup company for six
months and i got fired for being
insubordinate
communists just don't believe enough
yeah we need to believe that's the magic
dust that keeps communism going his
belief
um
i love eddie pepitone he's a leftist
like me
whatever it means to not work and get
the credit or resources for free yeah
like capitalists do they don't work they
just own a factory that their dad owned
and now they get free money and they get
to buy a yacht with all our hard-earned
money hard-earned work i thought you
were a social psychologist for a moment
hans thank you i am a social
psychologist
i uh i'm a psychologist and i'm very
social do you think the leviathan is too
strong how do you not lose hope
what is the leviathan we're using
biblical metaphors to describe politics
i do not lose hope because human beings
are what control the levers of power and
i'm a human being and all human beings
are going to die and be replaced so no i
don't lose hope i think that
the thing that's keeping it up is
selfish profit desires
um
why do you like cellulosic tan the
gamified version of capitalism i mean i
don't think all competition is
capitalism i think capitalism is um
where uh
where uh people who own capital get more
and more money and at least in catan
it's even everyone's a capitalist not
just workers versus capitalists
um
i uh
i like competition i like uh resources i
love uh you know accruing resources like
any monkey does um i don't think that uh
just
uh
focusing on that emotion
is healthy
and i think that it's good to
play it as a game
and i don't think it's good to do it to
your grandma and make her
uh destitute so you can make more money
but yeah i think
katan
is a great avenue to
express your
competitive drive
um
you seeing any music during
such
i hope so
how much you charging for a wedding
probably like five
five buckaroonies
i mean competition is a form of life
capitalists don't own competition you
can have a competition without
capitalism
um i mean what do you think people were
doing before the invention of capitalism
you think they were just all getting
along and holding hands they were all
competing then too we didn't we weren't
just waiting for capitalism to come
along to compete i mean the mongols
didn't have capitalism they were pretty
competitive
our fundamental issue is a lack of moral
framework economic system is not a
replacement for that
but uh economic system can inform your
moral framework and depending on what
kind of economic framework you're in it
could influence your morals
um and what's like i mean they have
leverage with partners and suicide
you've been smoking weed hans yeah
yesterday today i've been sober
uh do your farts smell like miso soup
today
they smell like miso soup
um only on december 7th
the day that we live in infamy
i drink miso soup in your honor brave
japanese dive bombers
um
i think crypto is um
is a nice piece of technology
i don't think betting on it is gonna do
much
i think that
um i'm gonna figure it out
matriarchal society
i don't know if just replacing one
gender for another is really gonna do
the trick i think women are generally
nicer but i think that we should have a
little more
um than just
switching the gender
um
uh do you think more as a comedian than
you did as an engine and subordinate
engineer do you make more
uh do i make more as a comedian yes i
mean i was making minimum wage as an
insubordinate engineer at a startup
company because that's the only job that
i could get out of college
um
i really did not do well in college i
got like a 2.7 2.6 gpa
i was just trying to get by um i lit
really learned a lot i cheated a lot
i try to cheat as much as possible
um but yeah i'm streaming right now for
gas and stuff but yeah i mean uh i
wasn't very good as an engineer i didn't
quit engineering because i was making
too much money it's like they rejected
me
um
and then i started doing my own thing
um
uh
who do that good kimchi smell like farts
when you open the jar if it don't stink
i don't want it i love kimchi
it's like
cold it's wet it's spicy it just adds a
different like when i'm eating like like
something and then it's like just bready
and heavy and like dry and then you put
in a little kimchi in there it's like
your mouth is like oh yeah this is like
the full palette of
taste
so now it informs the boring bready
thing
better
i don't know that much about ux design i
still do freelancing for autocad
um i make little autocad drawings for
some people
[Music]
my parents thought my decision to do
comedy was weird and of gamble but they
were happy that i found something
because before that i was getting
arrested for shoplifting getting caught
doing drugs
and just not doing anything with my life
so they were worried for me since high
school they were like what is this loser
gonna end up doing he has no
direction and then at least with comedy
i have a direction so they were like
okay he found something he likes to do
that's
relatively
uh financially lucrative
so yeah i mean
they're happy that i found something and
that i'm pursuing something that i like
to do they're a little more progressive
than most korean traditional families
because we learned our lesson there's
plenty of korean dramas about how to be
a shitty parent
you're we're paying for your gas right
now i hope so i don't know if i put ads
on this [ __ ]
um
but yeah i mean you're paying for
something it all goes into the bank
account and then it gets mixed in there
and then i use it
um
[Music]
yeah i mean
i do have 60 minutes i do um do comedy
um
i uh
i love uh
i uh i do love headlining
i think headlining is fun
um
i um
i can headline and i'd love to do it
does joe think gas is a renewable
resource i have no idea
that's a very specific question i didn't
get around to that one
i moved to austin in march of 2021
i've been here almost at one year
and my life has become
immeasurably better for moving here
it's amazing i was alone in the desert
enjoying my time alone
and um i was like you know what why
don't i just go back into society see
what i can do there
and uh all this amazing [ __ ] happens so
it's just really cool
that
um
i
uh it's just really cool that that
happened for me
that i could succeed inside
society because i was outside of it
so that's just cool
um
i mean oil
oil is good
oil is uh
not
we shouldn't like hold on to it we
should be like oh this is the only fuel
source for me that just seems a little
weird why why shouldn't we do anything
or everything
we should do a lot of different fuels we
shouldn't just stick to one thing
i mean if you want to own the libs you
could totally [ __ ] just focus on oil
for your whole life
but i mean it's like
why
you just want things to be the same you
just want to use gas engines for the
rest of your life
i mean don't you want to see what the
next step
in technology is
it just seems weird to just be focused
on oil
oil have you know that this gas is
making me gassy
um
i have solar panels on my car
and that powers a lot of stuff
i have a battery for the solar panels
um
yeah i mean what else is going on
should we watch some crazy videos on
youtube
um
there's a lot of options for what we
could do
i've been watching a lot of these uh
athletes
female athletes in track and field that
keep popping up in my algorithm
and it's really hypnotizing and hard to
not watch when i see women wearing
little panties bending over
and [ __ ]
it's just weird because
the female body is very attractive and i
like to stare at it for long periods of
time
[Music]
i could watch some
esl gsl
a little bit of starcraft and i could
comment on that um
it's just not something that i've done
[Music]
hail satan
andrew callahan channel
5. um
let me uh
see
there's a channel five i haven't seen
i mean i like it it's like an
exploration of humanity
um
it's just like sometimes they interview
people that are just really [ __ ] up
and stupid and crazy and it's just like
i don't want to know this much about
this idiot
but um
a lot of uh andrew callahan seems to
love
getting to know these people and
he loves um
talking to these people you know if he
he's
if he sees an art in that then i want to
see
him doing it
um
but yeah i mean it's hard for me to just
talk to like people that are clearly
broken because then it's like what if i
become broken or it's like is this like
a helpful thing to think like it's hard
for me to like have something to latch
on to and that
their craziness and learn anything from
that
um
hell fauci
um
i love duncan trussell
family hour
it's pretty good
um
i think that uh covet cases are almost
as high as they've ever been and mass
may needs are gone in my state
yeah i mean
luckily
omicron
isn't that deadly
so
i don't think it's uh
that big a deal anymore
um
obviously it shouldn't be that way we
should all uh have like
coveted
uh cases
uh and masks
line up so that when one goes up the
masks go up
um
i think that uh
our response to the coronavirus was very
much
broken because we're just fighting with
each other all the time we're just like
fighting between conservatives and
liberals mostly
so when something comes up
we just start attacking each other
instead of the virus so we're like you
want to do that i want to do this well
you want to do this i want to do that
and then we all we know how to do is
fight with each other and if the virus
isn't deadly enough to make us afraid of
it then we're just going to go back to
our
regularly scheduled fights
so we're just arguing with each other
um instead of fighting the virus
we're fighting each other because that's
all that's our habit it's just an old
tradition that we go back to whenever we
um
whenever we [ __ ]
get stressed out or bored we just start
yelling at each other
the virus started racism
wow i didn't realize the virus has been
around since the beginning of time
um
anyways i did an hour and a half i think
that's good enough uh thank you guys so
much
and i hope you have a good day